brian why do you support this idea of
building back better
because i support
stop
because i support not being the the only
country in the world uh not allowing its
government to negotiate lower drug
prices for people i believe that we
should expand medicaid uh to cover
vision hearing and dental so that the
people who need it most can get it i
support offering paid sick leave like
every other industrialized nation in the
world i support addressing climate
change even as storms and wildfires
destroy our infrastructure i think we
should modernize the electricity grid i
think we should allow for child and
elder care to free up caretakers to go
participate in the economy so they can
get jobs and stimulate the economy
you know not only does all of this make
sense it should be the bare minimum for
the most prosperous country in the world
just like it is for every other major
industrialized country in the world
michael
well i suppose
that all sounds very well and good if
i'm opposing this i suppose i oppose
building back better right but but i
think beyond those slogans which we
could all agree on yes we all want
children to be raised very well and we
all want everyone to be treated equally
and we want to protect the environment
and of course the question is is this
the way to do it this is a bill that is
going to cost three and a half trillion
dollars on paper but it's actually going
to cost a lot more than that
economic analysis has suggested it could
be as much as five and a half trillion
dollars and even the new york times
acknowledges that it's going to cost
much much more than three and a half
trillion dollars and so beyond all that
all the goodies and the freebies and the
very nice things that we all can agree
on let's look at what this law does that
is perhaps not so nice and not so
popular you've got a doubling of the
size of the irs and a lot of money being
spent to do that
and furthermore you're giving the irs in
this law the ability to look into your
bank account if you have more than 600
in that bank account so this is a huge
expansion of the administrative state
and the power of the federal government
to look into your affairs there are a
lot of payoffs to a public sector to
public and private sector unions i
suppose in here and this is because
they're a major constituency of the
democratic party and then there's this
issue of the debt i mean let's let's not
forget the numbers here it's not the be
all and end all but we have a 28
trillion dollar debt in this country
right now within 10 years debt to gdp
ratio is going to be well over 100
percent and this is a drag on the
economy and it also raises serious
political questions what kind of a
country is it that leaves as an
inheritance to the next generation lots
and lots of debt it's a national
security problem it it puts us in a
position of weakness and without very
much leverage to our greatest
geopolitical enemies notably china and
and it's an agenda that's not very
popular i think this is why joe biden's
approval rating even according to the
very left wing quinnipiac poll is is in
the 30s right now it's really really low
and i think it speaks to the
unpopularity of his broader agenda brian
do you think republicans have
consistently been focused on debt
yeah i i think uh i think starting
january 20th 2021 republicans have
started uh focusing on the debt uh
here's the thing first of all this bill
is paid for and it's paid for in ways
that are even more popular than the
actual provisions of the bill itself
it's paid for by raising taxes on
companies that don't pay it's paid for
by raising taxes on the ultra wealthy
those making over four hundred thousand
dollars a year it's paid for increasing
uh capital gains taxes on the wealthy
and like michael said by increasing irs
funding because for every dollar spent
the irs can generate six dollars in
returns from tax cheats so for those who
oppose this legislation it really does
speak volumes about the kind of people
that they're protecting the fact is that
the only reason that republicans oppose
this is because these provisions
threaten their entire reason for being
in government which is to cuddle the
rich the people who claim that we can't
afford these monumentally popular
provisions like the ones in the
buildback better act are the same people
who were frothing at the mouth when
republicans passed a 2 trillion tax cut
that overwhelmingly favored uh the rich
when you when you when you spend on the
ultra rich the deficit doesn't exist but
try to help a teacher or a secretary or
a nurse and suddenly we are ireland
during the great famine
your comment there michael
well i think we might have some common
ground here because i have absolutely no
problem having wealthy democrats pay
more money in taxes and let's not forget
the wealthy in this country are
disproportionately likely to vote for
democrats not republicans despite a
common misconception to the contrary i
have no problem having a giant woke
corporations uh paying more in taxes
that would be fine by me but what this
represents i think this this
biden agenda is is a power grab it is it
is a way to spend a lot of money to
entrench power to increase
federal spending as a percentage of the
economy pretty significantly and and to
to this point on the irs to give the
government a lot more power not just
over the wealthy who disproportionately
actually favor this agenda because they
have very good accountants who can get
around it anyway but but ordinary
americans anyone with more than 600
bucks in your bank account the
government's coming to look at your
books